dort wird gesponsert vom toyota auris
hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und wer
trotzdem elektrisch warum gehen wir nach
europa man erleben wir haben angst vor
dem es um den flugzeugen
warum was tun uns die vom sie wollen uns
töten
ja sie wollten uns
[Musik]
das ist meine familie meine frau fatima
mein sohn meine tochter bay an und mein
kleiner armer
[Musik]
es ist wichtig dass das schon richter
nach syrien können damit mehr über das
was dort vorgeht über die massaker über
die giftgasangriff über die schreckliche
verbrechen
diese russische bombe sollte uns töten
mit diesen bomben töten sie irgendwelche
leute auch kinder
pa immer schlechter gegangen und ich
glaube dass ich jetzt den nächsten zieht
nun in die region gang vielleicht schon
nach sicher nicht nach aus aleppo
das ist einfach wahr einen vierjährigen
mitglieder oder nicht fakt russische
luftangriff links im orange t shirt was
ich da macht mut und familie von mahmut
pet mri in syrien schützt also ein für
sie eine brühe dreistellig einig dass
schäfer von der liebe achter gesehen
also ich bin der schuld von der familie
gestand daraus honig zunächst empfunden
[Musik]
das ist meine stadt saß hier bin ich
geboren hier habe ich meine frau fatima
kennengelernt
das ist die straße in der wir gelebt
haben wir mussten weg freiwillig hätte
ich das nie verlassen
das ist meine heimat hier habe ich
meinen mann geheiratet
hier sind meine kinder zur welt gekommen
ich wünsche mir dass alles wieder so
wird wie früher als mädchen habe ich mir
gewünscht hübsche kinder und ein schönes
haus zu haben
auch dass die kinder eine gute
ausbildung bekommen aber es hat uns
nichts übrig gelassen
ich hoffe auch dass ich irgendwann
wieder zurückkehren kann nach syrien
nach ersatz so gut wie
die mehrheit der syrischen bevölkerung
war mit dem regime von assad nicht
zufrieden aber niemand getraute sich
darüber zu reden
es war ein horror das regime zu
kritisieren hätte ein todesurteil
bedeuten können
niemand ist nicht betroffen von syrien
ist nichts mehr übrig die kinder werden
heute geboren und morgen werden sie
getötet
alles ist kaputt es ist in die
katastrophe wir hatten einfach nicht das
glück ein normales leben zu führen
[Musik]
diese szene da kann ich mich genau
erinnern
ein flugzeug hat die westliche
nachbarschaft bombardiert ich fuhr mit
meinem bruder an wohin kurz war auch
dabei es gab 30 tote
[Musik]
nein ihr sucht am falschen ort das ist
die küche das ist die küche die lytro
maddox die uniformierte zum teil sind
später vom vom islamischen staat
entführt und umgebracht oder also viele
von denen haben
[Musik]
das ist ein freund und nachbar im
zerstörten haus haben seine verwandten
gelebt man hat sie noch nicht gefunden
[Musik]
ich hoffe immer dass es besser wird
aber es wird immer schlimmer und
schlimmer ich habe die hoffnung komplett
verloren das ist das ließ dörfler in der
neusser aus dem helikopter flugplatz k
so hat sich heute vom aussatz verschanzt
weil wir entschlossen uns der freien
syrischen armee an und kämpften mit der
brigade sturm des nordens ohne waffen
wären wir komplett geliefert gewesen ist
und mit langer hose
jetzt geht denn dort vergleiche ich habe
ich mir die kamera aus dem graben user
capt um die soldaten
wir sind 800 meter wachsen und die hand
sofort auf der kamera geschossen
also das sind vor coca cola und ich
hatte kaum anders denn mit den aufgaben
mit meinem hobby ich zittere und bekomme
angst wenn ich mir das anschaue
ich kann mich gut an diese situation
erinnern
sieben panzer haben uns attackiert und
wir konnten uns nicht schützen
es waren neun uhr abends als wir dann
einen panzer erwischt haben
und als dann der es plötzlich bei uns
auftauchte habe ich auch gegen diese
leute gekämpft
die fonds sind extrem sie kennen keine
gnade
sie kennen die kriegs regel nicht wenn
sie dich erwischen dann kennen sie nur
das messer und schneiden dir den kopf ab
und ich habe eine frau und kinder wir
wollen leben wir wollen nicht sterben
ich wurde am schluss vom regime und vom
es verfolgt
um die flucht zu finanzieren habe ich
mein haus verkauft 9000 dollar
es wäre doppelt so viel wert gewesen
aber ich war in not und musste schnell
loswerden und türkheim ganz normaler
reisebus oder große bootsführer lange
strecke und sie sind so einfach an und
flüchte ich bin 19 jahre alt und habe
drei jüngere schwestern und drei jüngere
brüder
ich habe den militärdienst verweigert
und weil ich auch meinem onkel an war
geholfen habe habe mein name auf eine
liste gegen den ie s haben wir auch
demonstriert ich werde von beiden seiten
gesucht vom regime und zu meinem onkel
mahmud habe ich ein sehr
freundschaftliches verhältnis
sie verbringen viel zeit miteinander wir
haben nur ineinander gewohnt als er sich
entschied nach europa zu gehen wollte
ich auch mit wir beide verfolgt wurden
er sagte ich sollte mich bereithalten
ist dass eltern haben geweint sie haben
gedacht er wird sterben
wir konnten nur wenige sachen mitnehmen
nur kleider
ich habe die sachen bewusst
zurückgenommen
weil es um leben und tod ging unsere
seelen sind da wichtiger als das was wir
besitzen
der erste schlepper verlangte für die
strecke von der türkei bis zur
griechischen insel samos 1.200 us dollar
pro person
die kinder galten als eine person also
insgesamt 3600 us-dollar
wir bereiten uns jetzt vor dass mehr zu
überqueren um zwei uhr morgens geht es
los
gerade eben haben wir die bestätigung
des schleppers bekommen das habe ich
gefilmt das war im hotel kurz vor der
überfahrt mit dem schlauchboot meine
lieben hört mir gut zu
wenn wir auf das boot gehen kann es sehr
wackelig werden passt gut auf dass
dieser gurt gut angezogen ist wenn etwas
schlimmes passiert und wir ins wasser
fallen dann habt keine angst
versucht euch einfach auf den rücken zu
legen spielt nicht mit dem gurt lasst
ihn immer fest verschlossen
es war alles sehr überraschend mit der
bootsfahrt ich wusste zum beispiel nicht
dass wir beim einsteigen erst mal durchs
wasser waten mussten
das war eineinhalb meter tief meinen
sohn musste getragen er hatte panik alle
haben gesagt dass er eine todesfahrt
machen etwas mehr
der schlepper übrigens ein palästinenser
der als flüchtling in syrien lebt hat
dem der das boot fuhr gesagt er solle
einfach in diese richtung fahren wo man
das licht auf einem berg sieht in diesem
licht haben wir einfach versucht zu
folgen strecke war ungefähr 20 km ich
hatte keine ahnung wo wir landen würden
gefühlt es gab vier situationen wo wir
fast gekentert
die hohen wellen fingen plötzlich an mit
dem boot zu spielen
habt ihr angst
es ist sehr kalt und ich bin ganz nah
hier haben wir uns ausgezogen
das ist die insel voller felsen die
ganzen menschen ziehen sich um
wir sind endlich angekommen ist auch
dabei gewesen
[Musik]
das auch dass du nicht runterfällt
wenn wir zu einem supermarkt kommen gibt
es dann etwas zu essen
ja wir hatten nichts zu essen
aber die kinder hatten durst und hunger
woher sollte ich dann etwas zu essen
organisieren
wir waren mitten auf einem berg wir
haben versucht die kinder bei laune zu
halten bis sie sich daran gewöhnt hatten
hier sind die leute die flüchtlinge
ruhen sich aus es ist irgendwie surreal
viele kleinkinder sind auch dabei wie
man sieht hast du hunger meine kleine
und durst wir mussten über zehn stunden
zu fuß gehen
[Musik]
lasst uns weiter gehen los und den
plötzlich hat mir jeder macht nur das
sehr geschickt und clyde yancy sie jetzt
an der küste und ich komm ich kann mich
abholen
auf samos wollten wir zum
polizeipräsidium um uns zu melden
aber wir waren zu spät darum mussten wir
eine nacht vor der polizeistation
verbringen
[Musik]
vor drei tagen haben wir dort hinten
unter den bäumen übernachtet 1 kein
hotel ohne papiere aufnehmen wollte die
kälte hat uns fast umgebracht weil wir
noch nass waren von der überfahrt wir
haben mit den drei kindern ohne decken
auf dem boden geschlafen
die verrückten es leute die es leute
töten kinder warum plötzlich wir schauen
weil ich den es nicht mag
[Musik]
ich will keine toten menschen mehr sehen
wie es leute sind verrückt diesen
verrückt der assets getötet
dass sie sich von dem trauma hohler dass
ich geschockt sie die überfahrt für sie
und darum haben kunden keinen einer an
strand und gucke mal wie das ist mit all
den touristen wurden lernen
in den rabatten
dieser teil der reise der jetzt hinter
uns liegt war wirklich hart wir
überquerten das meer und marschierten
durch die wälder während viele stunden
weinende kinder lagen auf dem boden mit
ihren eltern alle hatten entsetzliche
angst es war wortwörtlich 1 todestrieb
ich hoffe bucht wo hilft und wie ihr
dialekt erkennt und da eigentlich mit
mehr schon zürichsee darüber setzt das
ursprünglich aus liebe und erkennt also
syrische dialog also verdammen habe ich
das idealen und familie kennt eben das
hat auch wieder zurückgekehrt wenn man
sich aber schon vertraut
gut
[Musik]
erstmals sehe dass sie ein helikopter
hand war der nyt hilft und keine bomben
oder raketen ab ob er fotografiert
[Musik]
so wenn wir dann in athen sind dann wird
es von dort weiter gehen bis in den
norden von griechenland zu einer stadt
die heißt thessaloniki und sein auto ist
rot er hat immer wieder über die die
probleme geredet wo auf sie zukommen und
sich vor anspruch problem lässt dazu
dass sie in einem sprachkurs gay tony
das ist schwierig für fatima sie hat
drei kinder die sie zuerst einmal zu
betreuen hat der rest liegt in meiner
verantwortung verstehst du aber nein ich
habe kein problem mit all dem aber lasst
uns diese phase erstmal erreichen und
dann schauen wir weiter
ich glaube dass die das nicht ganz
einfach weiterhin der schweizer ihre
kultur ist extrem an dass apple die
stand ist extrem anders und es wird es
war der größte sache vor ihnen erwartet
die uns wofür sie nicht deshalb
verständlich sind er wird also frau zum
beispiel unser gott und im coop oder
migros goldkäufe frau agnes kuse und das
ist sicher ein großes problem wieder bei
der integration
[Musik]
ein teil vor vor unserer reise bezahlt
farid kann sie oft den tropen und ins
rechte hand im kader aber ziemlich black
book das handel bezahlt
[Musik]
es ist ein großes gefühl jetzt nach
athen zu fahren wieder einen schritt
vorwärts aber gleichzeitig mache ich mir
sorgen wegen ungarn
es heißt sie hätten die grenzen
geschlossen und ich weiß nicht wie wir
das machen sollen
sein
nein ich habe keine angst
wissen schon mal ein schiff gefahren
nein das ist das erste mal
[Musik]
klickt ihr netz es gibt leute aus dem
libanon dem irak usw
die sich einfach eine syrische identität
zulegen
in der türkei ist es einfach einen
gefälschten syrischem pass zu bekommen
oder auch eine identitätskarte oder
einen gefälschten syrischen führerschein
wir bewegen uns hier fahren
wir werden alles tun um nicht verhaftet
zu werden von der ungarischen polizei
wir müssen einen weg finden wenn sie
unsere fingerabdrücke in ungarn
registrieren
dann werden uns die schweizer nicht mehr
akzeptieren
[Musik]
kinder sind natürlich spielt gesehen und
fand das alles nicht so richtig
begriffen wenn es blöd dass ich mich für
sie eigentlich bedrohliche sehe aber die
man dann auf der riesige ferrari xi ich
machen sie das cool kids treff stark auf
die hand oder gar nicht kapiert ps und
der asta toten kinder
wir mögen die nicht wir hassen sie in
die schweiz
[Musik]
500 euro bis kopien ja also warten sie
mal geben sie mir ihre telefonnummer
[Musik]
hier müsste taxifahrer hat die 500 euro
wähler für führer strecke bis nach
skopje etwa behaupten uns bringen
und ich sage das nicht weil er glaube
dass bei uns tatsächlich über die
mazedonische grenze bringen und den für
ambri ist wirklich extrem günstig ist
für über 500 kilometer und er hat uns
dann entschieden dass nichts machen aber
will ich damit nie kalt und möglichst
schnell abhaken und mich ziemlich sind
sehr froh dass das rote karte
diese geschlossene facebook gruppe heißt
flucht nach europa in 20 tagen leute
helfen sich gegenseitig auf dieser
plattform wie sie ihre destinationen
erreichen können
es gibt viele kontakte von schleppern
das beginnt schon in der türkei izmir
[Musik]
diese leute haben kein gewissen
sie sind der grund warum dieses kind
ertrunken ist und viele andere auch aber
ohne ihre hilfe hätten wäre es auch
nicht geschafft aber das sind keine
menschen
jetzt schreibt gerade einer einer
eilmeldung das heißt ungarn hat nun
offiziell mitgeteilt dass sie die
grenzen schließen alle die illegal über
die grenze kommen müssen mit bis zu drei
jahren gefängnis rechnen
deutschland hatte auch die grenzen dicht
gemacht merkel hat die flüchtlinge
willkommen geheißen
auch das deutsche volk sagte sie wollen
die tore öffnen für die flüchtlinge und
jetzt wo ich in griechenland beschließen
sie die grenzen ungarn und deutschland
wer weiß welches land es ihnen gleichtun
wird die drohnen uns mit gefängnis in
ungarn
ich habe ja meine frau und die kinder
bei mir was sollen wir jetzt machen
ich meine wir haben schon so eine lange
reise hinter uns von syrien über die
türkei auf dem meer haben wir den tod
ins auge geblickt und jetzt sind wir
hier und die schließen die grenzen
die spielen mit uns ich habe alles was
ich hatte in dieser reise investiert
sag ihm dass wir sicher durch ungarn
wollen und dann weiter nach deutschland
oder in die schweiz versucht es nochmal
er geht nicht ran
er ist mein papa er versucht einen
schlepper zu erreichen
hier hat es lepper von serbien nach
deutschland oder österreich oder belgien
er geht nicht dran macht mut feldversuch
die schleppe kontaktieren
aber keine von denen 1 telefon gegangen
um mir sind demnach nur los war aber mit
dem 2
[Musik]
wir brauchen tickets für den zug nach
thessaloniki ist schon mal zu befahren
nein das ist das erste mal wir sind acht
personen in griechenland ist es im sumo
eigentlich jede hilfe flüchtlingstrecks
also sogar ein flüchtling umar baza und
dick sind jetzt kann dort war dann viele
kirche müsse das nicht zu rechnen dass
das jetzt anders steht und warum hat man
eigentlich immer mehr papier vor wiese
haben sie papiere
ja natürlich da macht man hätte auch
kein pass und fátima nett aber kirche
handelnden tierische papier
so kann sie transit papier ausgestellt
nachlässe passe
der zug fährt um sex von diesem
bahnsteig
vielen dank auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
dieser plan jetzt aus welche route wollt
ihr nehmen wir wollen nach kroatien aber
es hängt von den schmugglern ab und es
dann doch rumänien ist auf der facebook
gruppe habe ich gelesen dass es dort
auch einen weg gibt durch rumänien
aber ihr wisst schon dass die strecke
über rumänien viel weiter ist
was sollen wir machen wir müssen da
jetzt durch
wir können nicht zurück nicht nachdem
wir den gefährlichsten teil wie das meer
geschafft haben
[Musik]
es hat gewackelt und gewackelt die leute
haben geschrien du hast geschlafen im
boot nicht wahr
ich hab ihn geweckt ich wollte nicht
alleine sein ich war die ganze zeit wach
auf dem boot
ich fühle mich jetzt gut
ich hoffe einfach dass wir sicher und
gesund ankommen
[Musik]
du hast mich vor ein paar tagen erzählt
dass du in izmir oder auf samos erfahren
hast dass deine mutter dich verlobt hat
ja als wie einsam aus ankamen habe ich
das herausgefunden dass wir euch
getroffen haben im hotel
warum gerade jetzt ist es weil deine
mutter stolz auf dich ist dass du es
nach europa geschafft hast
nein es war ihr wunsch dass ich noch
heiraten bevor ich abreise so hat sie
mich wenigstens verlobt wenn sie ihren
namen hast du sie schon gesehen ein foto
nein bis jetzt weiß ich absolut nichts
und glaubst du dass es funktioniert ohne
dass du sie kennst ja ich vertraue
meiner mutter sie kennt meinen geschmack
inzwischen hätten wir ab und zu und ich
habe ein foto von ihr gesehen und die
asi gefällt mir sehr gut
meine mutter hat das gut gemacht
natürlich möchte ich dass meine verlobte
auch in die schweiz kommen kann
[Musik]
dann haben wir bald merkt dass die
taxifahrer bei uns vom bahnhof bis zur
grenze ringe die wissen ganz genau wo
man über moore ist das mainevent über
offizielle gehirn zu übergangen benutzt
die letzten meter müssen sie zu fuß über
die grenze
und als polizei stück stand und wenn die
fahrt mit flüchtlingskindern handwerkers
oder weg vom offiziellen zu bekommen und
den hinterausgang und könnte schnell
bitter
hier sind wir an der griechisch
mazedonischen grenze
da waren verschiedene organisationen und
das rote kreuz oder der rote halbmond
das weiß ich nicht mehr
wir haben essen und kleider verteilt
werden
jetzt hat er nicht mehr kalt wie
verklärungen ich glaube alle europäer
sind sehr menschlich sie mögen meine
kinder und respektieren die flüchtlinge
in der türkei ist das komplett anders
[Musik]
gern geschehen
aber
aber heute wurden die möbel ist ganz
sind ganz frisch es auch was liebt er es
quasi abraten und schwer sind um sie zu
drängen
[Musik]
hier sind wir in belgrad angekommen
ich hatte wirklich angst vor ungarn ich
dachte wenn sie die grenzen schließen
dann ist es vorbei für uns
rundum busbahnhof und normale bahnhof
der flüchtlinge im land und der timeline
genannt und das ist auch unsere
überlegung wert würde mir einen
schlepper finder wo sie nach kroatien
bringt und am schluss ist dann nicht
nötig sehen wir haben uns der grund ich
bediene aber vielleicht schon ein auto
sind es genau funktioniert
[Musik]
warum können wir nicht nach ungarn die
grenze ist geschlossen
wir haben einen zaun errichtet also eine
schlechte idee
was wenn sie dort unsere fingerabdrücke
nehmen
da steckst du fest dann geht es nicht
mehr weiter so und wo wirst du die nacht
verbringen
[Musik]
juni
dass sich dort einfach der neutrale
beobachter bb und einfach dass halo
passiere hätte natürlich damit zu tun
dass ich mir vorstellen dass ich immer
eine schöne hotelbett und so über nacht
und ziege die busse schlaflos oder in
irgend einen überfüllten bus oder in
irgend ne lastwagenfahrer los wo sie am
schluss so stickel
das habe ich schon ich wähle ihnen
zumute aber eher nicht mehr zu ermorden
sie haben den ganzen erdball räume sie
und das ist natürlich da für kinder das
ist einfach viel entspannter
ich habe noch nie fische gesehen weil
fische tief im meer sind mehrere mit
[Musik]
wie war die busfahrt fatima
irgendwann fing es mich furchtbar an zu
jucken
ich musste mich die ganze zeit kratzen
vielleicht habe ich dort irgendwo läuse
eingefangen
die hand sich natürlich große sorgen
gemacht wo der hype gesehen wie sie sich
das ja alles nicht so recht vorstellen
unerhört immer mehr überfordern
schlepper und von denen atomkerne
das ist für die der hype leben ganz
schwierig das zu beurteilen was ist
jetzt könig was ist nicht gefährlich ja
wir sind gesund hier angekommen
es ist sehr anstrengend aber wir kommen
langsam vorwärts
schritt für schritt
morgen geht es weiter
wir werden sie nein wir gehen nicht nach
deutschland und auch ungarn ist ein
großes problem
ich kann mit der familie nichts
riskieren es ist eine sehr lange reise
das macht uns zu schaffen
aber uns geht es besser als vielen
anderen
[Musik]
also ihr seid bis jetzt durch mazedonien
durchgefahren und diaz belgrad in
serbien
ihr habt jetzt ungefähr die hälfte des
weges egal wo ihr durchgeht
es bleibt ein risiko das wir verhaftet
wäre mir haben ist mir seniorin vor dass
das geschäft gut dass man uns fest nimmt
muss irgendwelche grün das ist verdammt
winkt mit flüchtlingen dora aber mich an
einer straßensperre in eine
polizeikontrolle und den den kurz ganz
anders aber und das haben die wähler
verhindere
und darum haben wir eigentlich versucht
die mutter tot überzüge dass sie bis
heute mehr riskante autofahrer oder auf
der straße vielleicht das kopftuch mal
für fünf minuten absieht damit nicht
ganz so oft
also wir sind ein team und ich muss mit
ihr über alles offen reden und alle
haben das recht ja oder nein zu sagen
also denkst du es wäre möglich damit wir
einen guten weg durch kroatien und
slowenien finden dass fatima
vorübergehend ihr kopftuch auszieht
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht recht
ich muss sie fragen ich kann sie nicht
zwingen es geht nicht darum dass kaum
ist sie aus der heimat saß ford muss sie
alles was sie glaubt und ihre prinzipien
über bord werfen
es geht darum ein kleines opfer zu
bringen und vielleicht so die ganze
gruppe zu retten ich konnte es nicht ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen kein kopftuch
zu tragen
ich trage es seit meiner kindheit es
fällt mir schwer ist abzunehmen
es ist ein teil von mir geworden
in syrien sind koffern haben wir schon
immer man das gibt es nicht also
jedenfalls nicht auf dem land und das
ist für sie sicher extrem und sie dass
sie von einer fremden frau fast wäre
optimal zum beispiel hätten mehr wo sie
mir kennt hat mir bis vor kurzem mit
hardcover leider körperkontakt ich nehme
duo taboo und dass das so gut das ist
für sie sich aber total ungewohnt und
maschine ganz einfach was im kopf den
abguss europäischen das frauenbild wie
fühlt es sich an einen haarschnitt von
einer frau zu bekommen
das ist sehr neu das gibt es in syrien
so nicht aber es ist angenehm
sie steckte plötzlich ganz schnell
korte hat plötzlich kennt quasi
aufgemachte sind ja sehr viel mühe
verhalten der hand und da hält man sich
nicht gut müsse informieren wochen tour
und was mir schon vorher gewarnt an der
grenze zu mazedonien und es hätte immer
an der grenze flüchtlingslagers oder
durchgangsland und half und die halt
vorhanden können so oft war ich sicher
dass keine miene verhalten
und wenn man den mann noch an der grenze
gesehen ich hätte meine begriffe wissen
konnte
erhalten sie hier bitte fátima hast ein
bisschen schlafen könnt nein ich habe
nicht geschlafen
es kommen unheimlich viele menschen
gestern mussten viele menschen die nacht
überbringen vorgestern die wogen
hochgegangen es hat proteste gegeben
[Musik]
das ist die kroatische polizei ist super
nett zu uns ja man ich würde dich
glücklich wird nie geglaubt dass ich das
jemals über polizei sagen super nett die
helfen und immer nicht alle
aufsichtlichen hat in den sinn grenzen
zu schließen weil es sowieso durch die
kroaten und slowenen einfach nur durch
freuen und sie sehen jedermanns
interesse ist so schnell wie möglich zu
durch zu leisten ist dahin
[Musik]
aus afghanistan das sind das im
fernsehen in afghanistan
er hat also fern sind dass deutschland
700 tausend flüchtlinge will dass die
dass die deutschen flüchtlinge brauchen
dass die mehr mehr leute brauchen und
700.000 und es halt aus dem fernsehen
die machen bewerbungen im fernsehen
[Gelächter]
aber ich meine dass ich das kann mich
komplett frei erfunden seien
die menge ist dahin
wir sind einfach losmarschiert wir
mussten sehr sehr lange zu fuß gehen
[Musik]
dass am schluss denn cortesi in duisburg
hand und doch nach ungarn gefahren
das ist für uns ein riesen schock ich
war überrascht über die vielen
sicherheitskräften umgang ball nach
wir haben in zelten übernachtet es hat
geregnet und unser zelt war kaputt
wir wurden ganz nass als der kleine aber
krank wurde gab es eine arzt nein es gab
keinen arzt aber ich habe versucht den
kleinen zum schwitzen zu bringen
ich habe wirklich alles versucht ihr gut
auf die kinder aufgepasst während die
reise damit sie auch heil ankommen habe
nie gewusst wie das denn
aber irgendwie hat doch schafft er das
kurze stück vor dem lager um es ja immer
braucht denn bis an die österreichische
grenze saldo aus eigener kraft
rückschläge wir hatten drei nächte
praktisch nicht geschlafen und kroatien
bis wir angekommen sind keine pause mehr
wir mussten immer weiter reißen war da
schon saß bis nach österreich waren es
21 tage
[Musik]
gerade in österreich einmal eigentlich
nummer im auto keine sie also nun selbst
mein kleid lockt war nach polizei
erhalten dann kracht's problem in der
hand versucht also ich habe erst richtig
freunde versuch das hotelzimmer und
allerhand abgelehnt allen upgrade wenn
man nicht offizielle dokumente kann man
nicht irgendwo übernachten
[Applaus]
jetzt sind wir in der schweiz
nein wir sind in österreich noch 15
kilometer dann sind wir in der schweiz
dann haben wir es geschafft ich würde in
die schweiz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir haben ein gutes gefühl
ja wir sind noch nicht angekommen das
müssen wir aber wir haben trotzdem ein
gutes gefühl
[Musik]
nach der brücke ist die schweiz der
polizei begegnen dann keine panik es ist
ja die schweizer polizei und bei denen
meldet ihr euch sowieso sofort
[Musik]
gott sei dank wir sind heil angekommen
das musst du jetzt noch schweizerdeutsch
sagen ich möchte so gern diese sprache
lernen ist ja schön dass du auch gut
angekommen bist danke
sie flüchten natürlich generell vor
gewalt und und vorstellig das jetzt da
die lupe genommen weil sie muslime sind
irgendwelche terrororganisationen war
das ist irgendwie absurd wie viele
flüchtlinge vor der qual
die haben genug vom köpfe folgen von
moses vom bombardieren die waren einfach
einen friedlichen habe und sie waren vor
allem das ist eigentlich wichtigste
motiv wieder meisten flüchtlinge nicht
sehen
sie waren das jährliche doch eine
entschuldigung und keine zukunft hat
[Musik]
syrien haben wir hinter uns gelassen wir
wollen vergessen und hier ein neues
kapitel beginnen
die kinder sollen eine gute ausbildung
bekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es war die richtige entscheidung in die
schweiz zu kommen
wir haben die bomben den lärm die
luftwaffe das blutvergießen unter
zivilisten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
manchmal wenn ich ins bett gehe
dann kommt die reise wieder in meinem
kopf
[Musik]
jetzt spielen wir fertig oder
doch mit toyota auris hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und fährt
trotzdem elektrisch